[Music]
the guard to know my fries you know my
ways the path he'd know me better than I
know myself and you've known me longer
anyone knows such knowledge is too
wonderful I can't even understand such
knowledge is too wonderful
I can't he come here no you see the
dance where I went I'd see you so good
[Music]
where my world is shaking your hand
whoa Meester the word even where my
world is shaken
[Music]
hello and good evening to all of you out
there and welcome to the table my name
is Maggie Tilford and I am on the
leadership team here and I just have to
say how very grateful and honored I feel
to share this face with you tonight
we are a newer community and based out
of saxy with the goal to shift a
generation from reactionary to visionary
through the person and work of Jesus
Christ and our hearts desire here is to
be a community who's practicing being
communal being vulnerable inclusive
eclectic and there's one other one
thoughtful so if this is your first time
and you haven't joined us before we just
welcomed you into this space and we hope
that you are experiencing and getting a
taste of some of those values that I
just named and if you've been with us
for a while or you consider this place
home we invite you back into that
journey of walking and living out those
things together and this is a space
where we want to practice that so we
welcome you in and I don't have a lot of
announcements for us tonight since
you know our world's going crazy people
it's a crazy space that we're living in
but one thing that we do just want to
continue to stress is just the
importance of having people that were
sharing life with that we're talking
with that we're wrestling through the
world that we live in the space and the
time that we inhabit right now and all
that's going on and that we aren't alone
in this journey so if you want to go to
our website it's the table TX comm and
go to the tab on meetups throughout the
week we have several groups that are
available for you to join in one for
teens and one for men and there's
several that are just open to all
there's a book club that's you know
meeting every week studying a particular
book together there's so many different
avenues and areas of interest there that
basically our goal is just to make homes
that are available for you and even
right now when we're not always able to
meet in person we still are continuing
those groups online or finding creative
ways to connect and challenge and love
one another well so we invite you to do
that you can fill out the info form
there to get more information or you can
always email us at info at the table DX
org as well if you have any more
questions we're happy to help in
whatever way we can and I have the
privilege of just turning this service
over to one of my favorite musicians
that I've ever had the privilege of
knowing and this is someone who's been a
supporter and contributor to the table
in big and small ways and and in
certainly relationally from the very
beginning and he's blessing us with his
presence on his guitar tonight so Jesse
watts is gonna lead us in some worship
before we dive into the rest of the
service so I just invite you to open up
your
heart and prepare for that time together
and let's go let's worship
hello friends my name is Jesse and I am
so blessed to get to be spending time
with you today in worship you know I've
noticed lately as we are in these times
that we're in a pandemic of racial
injustice and I find myself breathing
more and more shallow that I am not
taking deep breaths anymore you know I
don't know if it's the stress or the
anxiety or you know the tension I don't
I don't really know what it is but I'm
just not taking deep breaths anymore and
so I wanted to open this time with a
time of breathing a time when we could
breathe in peace breathe in joy breathe
out in anxiety or stress or worry so
let's take some time for deep breaths
[Music]
will you pray with me open why the
window of our spirits Oh Lord and fill
us with light open wide the door of our
hearts that we may receive and entertain
me with all our powers of adoration and
love amen
[Music]
for me and closer close to your heart
may not be a pure oh you are the
love that is patient love that is kind
love keeps no wrongs in mine my heart is
in space
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
my heart is no bin space you to come my
heart is no bin space you to come
[Music]
although are thirsty all the are come to
the fountain and tip your heart in the
stream of the teen and star be washed
waves of Mercy this deep cries out
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus Jesus Jesus in these times that we
can't really make a lot of sense of a
lot of us don't know what to say don't
know what to do how to engage how not to
engage God there's so much uncertainty
God it is in that place that we want to
declare that we are open God that we are
of an open space for you to inhabit we
are ready to receive your words receive
your love to receive you and it is from
that space that we humbly asked come
Lord Jesus come we're thirsty for
justice we are thirsty for healing and
is from that space that we say holy
spirit come come Lord Jesus come Holy
Spirit come we ask this in your powerful
and beautiful name amen
amen Thank You Jessie hi everyone
my name is Karen miner and I am a member
of the leadership team here at the table
and it is my honor and privilege to get
to facilitate a very special panel
discussion tonight entitled truthful
speech and faithful listeners and I am
so glad that you're here for this and
joining us we've been in a series
focusing on lament which we've been
defining as giving voice to our grief
and obviously with Kevin 19 and all of
the ongoing racial and Justices there's
been no shortage of things and
situations and people to grieve and
lament over we've looked at scriptures
from the songs and the prophets giving
us examples of truthful speech no
sugarcoating no tiptoeing around cutting
to the quick not tying a pretty bow on
it and we've also looked at the role of
faithful listeners just being
trustworthy empathetic very present and
staying away from distancing thoughts
and prayers and empty platitudes like
really truly and deeply abiding with and
solidarity with so truthful speech and
faithful listening our mutual acts of
love their acts of worship trust and
giving the faithful listener saying love
me enough to tell me the truth and the
truth teller saying love me enough to
listen believe and understand it's
mutual this is the kind of community
that we along to be and we don't want to
shrink back from addressing or
processing what's happening right now
together so for our panel tonight we're
going to hear from three of my favorite
people
we have Juanita Johnson yes
we've got India CERN and we've got Chris
Brown hello hi thank you thank you so
much for being here
it felt like a big ask a few days ago
when we reached out to you and asked if
you'd be a part of this panel discussion
and just in light of the latest news
about Rashard Brooks Ryan Milton Dominic
fells and more it feels like an even
bigger ask so thank you so much for
being willing and for being present even
in the midst of your own heaviness and
grief yeah I really just want to
underscore what a gift this is to our
table community and I also don't want to
advantage take advantage of or exploit
anything you guys have to give tonight
your time your words your emotional
labor your experiences yeah I mean it
there's no expectation for you to replay
trauma or tear just so just for others
to become more aware so I want you to
feel free to share openly and honestly
but not share anything that would bring
further trauma or qualms to you we want
to protect that right now so how about
if we dive in sounds good
sounds good so we'll start peep
may no you people may not know you I
don't want to assume so I thought we
would kick this off by having each of
you share a little bit about yourself
what makes you you and how you're
connected to the table who would like to
start I can start hi my name is India
I'm 16 years old and I've not been the
most connected to the table I've been
connect I was connected to New Hope
Lucas and I'm also a part of the girls
group for the table and I am very
thankful to have this opportunity to
just have a conversation honest and
truthful I know a lot of the leaders
here and we're I'm very close friends
look most people at the table so yeah
that's just me I can go next
my name is Juanita it's on the screen
and I am one of the elders at the table
and you know just happy to be a part of
this community and I just yeah I'm
thankful for this opportunity glad to
share glad that it's that it's a space
to be honest and open so yeah looking
forward to our discussion okay I'll
conclude uh my name is Chris I'm 52
years old and I guess my connection
would be more transition to the table um
you know going from New Hope Wiley to
Lucas and then ultimately to the table
and I would say it's the genuine message
the community that exists and an
openness to help people in their issues
and
I can you know honestly say it's made a
difference in my life and that's why I'm
here thank you
so first I'm curious to know how each of
you has been processing the last month
it's been full there's been a lot and so
I just like to hear from each of you and
your perspective how you
you've been processing through all of
that so one you dad could you sure so
how have I been processing the last
month it has been heavy it's been a
heavy heavy month we're all experiencing
the pandemic and the effects of
confusion with regard to you know this
health crisis that we're all in but to
be experiencing that on top of just
continual racial animus and inequity and
death has been really heavy
I'm really tired today and like my sleep
is off and just it's just been a
difficult month I was thinking of a
quote from James Baldwin he he said you
know to be black and conscious in
America is to be in a relative state of
rage and that is kind of a good picture
of this last month for me and rage is
exhausting and because it's it
free just not just about anger it's also
about grief
it's about hurt it's about
disappointment and fear and so to to be
carrying all of that for such a long
time on top of all of the pandemic mess
is just exhausting so that kind of where
I've been at for the last month Chris
how about you you know ironically I
would have to say rage a lot of
frustration and I guess predominantly
from a standpoint as someone who can
empathize with police officers haven't
been a police officer in the past for
almost six years just seeing their
behavior you know what comes across it
frustrates me it's not just training
it's public service my blood pressure
has been high all the time and I'm
trying to understand you know what is
going on you know looking at the message
looking at the training looking at the
circumstances and oh it just comes back
to there are different values on
different lives in our society and part
of its communication you know I tell
people all the time we're all different
everyone has value but if we don't
communicate and get our messages across
or openly listen we're gonna continue to
have the problems and and that's you
know what I see and that's why I wanted
to speak we can have those differences
we may not even agree and but that's
okay that's what you know I learned in
the military so it's very frustrating
and I'm getting accustomed to this and
they just have to pray a lot about it
but anger frustration just a lot of
emotions
how about you enjoy I think confusion
has been a big part of how I've been
feeling as a teenager it's hard to
understand how my friends and my family
especially can not understand that there
is a problem in America and that I am
scared that my father is scared my
stepdad is scared you know my black
family we're scared and it's confusing
to me that my friends and my family a
lot of them don't want to acknowledge or
have the pride to acknowledge what's
happening because it is an uncomfortable
conversation and because they are
uncomfortable with talking about what's
happening I think especially being so
young a lot of my friends they were
raised a certain way and it's really
been hard to continue to talk to them
and try and educate them with grace
because you know I'm angry and I'm hurt
and I'm scared and when my friends the
people that I love the most you know
don't really understand that and are
ignorant about it especially being like
teenagers it's been stressful and hard
to try and have a conversation without
getting upset and heated and feeding
into a stereotype so I think I've just
been very confused that's what I'll say
yeah and India I know also for you
there's been an added layer just recent
students starting to speak up about
racism homophobia bullying things
they've been experiencing
in the school district and at the same
time not being at school right now
because of the pandemic I'm wondering
how you've been how you've been
processing and working through that
stuff it's been difficult because a lot
of people that I know have after many
years of facing abuse or discrimination
against they finally come out and talked
about what's happening really behind
closed doors and why the ISD
specifically and the high schools
especially there is a lot of unsaid
discrimination a lot of people for
example I as a mixed person have been
told by a lot of people you know you're
whitewashed you're not black enough
you don't speak black you're not in
touch with your culture and it's kind of
confusing to me because you know what
what is being black enough
what is speaking black what is whitewash
how can you act a color how it's it's
heartbreaking that this you know goes on
and sometimes administration you know
chooses not to really just try and
understand or hear us and so I'm
thankful that Wiley ISD has been
listening are trying to listen and I'm
hoping as a senior next year I can step
up I can help and speak out and call
people out whenever they're being
insensitive or you know being rude not
not thinking about their words and I'm
hoping that my generation can be the
change and that's kind of what's giving
me hope is that a lot of people are
speaking out and a lot of people are
talking about it now and I'm hoping that
that's gonna make a change in why the
ISD especially high schools yeah
um just hearing hearing all of you share
and also thinking about it just with the
added context of we're in a pandemic and
we've been distancing physically and
that makes it hard to really have a lot
of community around you to process and
lament and events and rage and talk and
share and so I'm wondering and this is
for anybody who wants to answer how how
how and where are you able to process
through this where do you have these
conversations how do you how are you
able to talk talk through it I'll go
ahead you know for me a lot of family
support connections with co-workers and
trying to make sure that they're doing
well so in a way it opens up some dialog
helps you to understand that you're not
alone you know telework and working from
home is extremely stressful frustrating
and then it comes back to my wife you
know being in a mixed marriage with all
the topics we have real dialogue and
with Siena
so sometimes and it's something we've
always had and I think now it allows me
to understand that I just can't contain
it all I need to express and talk to
someone sometimes there are no answers
because some people you know I remember
back in college they knew the truth but
the way they were raised is what was
their foundation or common ground any
refused to make changes and some of
these people became teachers so that's
what I leave in it people can be
ignorant they can be educated but they
can be ignorant
so those are some ways that I've coped
with the current situation
yeah I'm a little bit different I very
much an internal processor and so the
more that's happening the more that I
need to kind of isolate so that I can
process my own thoughts and emotions but
being how are in a pandemic and all of
this is happening
I find myself reaching points where I
cannot contain it anymore like there's
so much inside that if I don't get it
out like I feel like I'm gonna come out
of my skin and so I've been doing a
little bit more writing if they end up
on Facebook if you've read any of my
recent rants and then when I feel like I
have language sometimes I'm able to
share with you know Mindy and Maggie and
kind of talk through some things but
even then it is every day is a new
tragedy and it's very difficult to be a
black woman in a majority white space
right now because the grief is so
personal right like there's not there's
only so much relating that we can do so
so yeah so it's it's difficult my outlet
right now is just when I it gets too
much I just ran on Facebook for a while
and and try and let it out that way and
then you know when I have language
talked it to people but even then it's
that's limited that's a limited carrying
there's still so much that you carry on
your I have a really large immediate
family who I'm thankful they let me rant
they let me talk and recently my mom has
let me my mom my stepdad
they let me make signs and put them out
in the front yard and just to show like
people that you know I'm thinking about
you and you matter and I understand
what's going on and I've used social
media as an outlet a lot but there comes
a time when social media can get too
toxic and I've needed to unplug
sometimes even though like especially
right now I feel like I have to be
educating and putting out stories and
sharing and reposting it can get
heartbreaking to continue seeing
tragedies and that's the time when I
just need to unplug and talk to my mom
my dad and it's you know it's it's hard
and whenever I am in a mixed race family
so it's hard when some of my closest
family members don't even want to have a
talk or understand what's going on so
that's when I really have to rely on my
my mom and my dad and my friends so I
can rant and I can just talk especially
you know going to the black lives matter
gathering in downtown Wiley that was
just a huge release for me internally I
needed I needed to hear and I needed to
listen to others people's perspectives
and I think that was like that was one
of the huge releases for me during this
time right now
thank you I'm also thinking about how
this this moment this cultural moment
that we're in right now and all the
awareness is not new like this is the
first time we've been through this and
yet there are a lot of people that are
becoming more outspoken becoming aware
and so I'm I'm curious how second
imagine that feels awesome you know I
mean it yeah it's great that people are
becoming more aware and and learning and
educating but it's at the same time I
would imagine there's also just some I
don't know I want to put words in your
mouth but anger or frustration like
where have you been
you're going on forever and ever and
ever and so I'm wondering how how you're
handling that piece of it how are you
processing this moment in the context of
your birth experience in your lifetime
I'm really hoping that this isn't just a
trend you know something for a couple of
weeks and I I hope this is continued to
be talked about because it's been
happening for so long and you know we're
finally kind of at the breaking point
and it continues to keep happening so
I'm hoping that whenever this starts
kind of boiling down and it's not as
heated no one talking about it as much I
find I would find support and people who
continue to educate themselves and
continue to speak out and even when this
isn't a trend that's really what I'm
feeling about the whole situation yeah
that's really good I yeah I have the
same hope and the same fears of this
just being really trendy at the moment
this being really like you know a lot of
people speaking out like I get that the
video of George Floyd was really
traumatic for a lot of people it was
their first time they really felt it in
their bodies but you know for me that
you know that this was not my first time
feeling it in my body so but at the same
time it also feels very much like a lot
of people are just covering their
behinds like it's really popular right
now to be able to say black lives matter
but what does that really mean in terms
of actions and change behaviors
and kind of took Chris's point earlier
about ignorance ignorance is a choice
and I feel like because we're all
trapped at home and we can't do anything
else but watch the world fall apart it's
really trendy and really you know the
politically correct thing right now to
be on board but when the same protester
acts asking people to change behaviors
asking for new legislation new ways to
think about policing when it when the
rubber meets the road are we going to
continue educating ourselves and pushing
forward so this doesn't have to continue
happening and that is that is what I
want to talk about I don't want to I
don't want to grieve anymore I want to
talk about how do we move forward if
this is something that you really mean
something to you how are you continuing
to educate yourself and pursue justice
and pursue be an active participate in
pursuing peace for everyone because
black lives are not a trend they're not
a way for you to feel good about
yourself in the moment this these are
our lives so it's it's I guess what's
hard for me is that as a black male I've
become so callous because in society and
through interactions I see how much I'm
valued and how much I'm not I would like
to believe in hope that people were
sincere with change but a lot of people
don't want to change yeah
and if this hadn't been documented and
if accountability hadn't been pressed
nothing would be occurring and you know
that really bothers me two things can
happen you know people
you can see what's occurring make make
conscious change or create more division
so for me that's one of two things are
gonna happen we're gonna either address
the issues or we're gonna be more
divisive and you know look at I hate to
say it look at all the violence that
occurs with all that pent up it's not an
excuse for the behavior but it's a sense
of hopelessness and when people have
nothing to hope or live for it's basic
survival they just don't care that's why
we're having what occurs and you know
having to tell my daughter how to behave
if we get stopped by the police or how
to behave or to document what occurs
that's not what I need to tell a
thirteen-year-old and sadly I'm glad I
don't have a son I'm glad to have a
daughter and that's the world I live in
and I have to explain to her it's not
evil and it never will be
I don't like having that discussion with
her but that's just how I feel about
this
so what what is it that that keeps you
showing up during times like this
because it seems extremely difficult and
excruciating at times to continue to
show ups and I'm specifically I don't
want to tiptoe around it I'm
specifically talking about a majority
white church like the table and like
others you may have been a part of what
keeps you showing up during times like
this I think seeing the support from my
white friends or even just people
listening I'm wanting to understand and
having a conversation that's way keeps
me motivated it's my future now I'm so
young and I have to hopefully I'm gonna
be here for a long long long time and I
don't want to have to tell my
children how to act whenever a police
officer pulls them over and I don't want
to have to tell my children how to walk
how to address because you know I don't
want you to compete conceived a certain
way so I'm motivated because it's my
future and I want it to be different
whenever I'm older and I want it to be
different whenever my kids grow up my
grandchildren I want it to be different
for the future so that's my motivation I
think for me I think it's so it's hard
to show up it is I think the last couple
weeks I actually I didn't show up to the
table for the elderly things it is it is
hard to show up I think what keeps me
connected and what has me tied to the
table specifically our values and I know
that our community is committed to those
values of thoughtfulness and inclusivity
and being eclectic and that if we so my
hope is that if we can allow those
values to guide us that we will be a
community that is active and bringing
peace into the world but at the same
time I think where I'm at in life is I
am I am no longer willing to be a
participant in my own oppression and so
I am prioritizing right now especially
right now prioritize kind of caring for
myself and being protective of my own
health and well-being and if and if just
me just laying it all on the table like
I won't participate in a community that
is comfortable with the status quo is OK
with just being good people and not
willing to be peacemakers in the world
and peacemakers are active they do the
work of justice and so that is the table
is young and we've been stifled by the
pandemic but you know as an elder as
someone committed to these values this
is something that I I want to see the
table move into and really flourish and
I think I think we have people who are
willing and committed and as long as
people are willing and committed I am as
well.these this is my family this is you
know there's it means so much to me but
at the same time this the last you know
month has solidified for me that that I
will not yeah I will not be a
participant in my own oppression and I
will not uphold
I will not uphold oppression and so I
will show up as long as we're doing the
work of tearing down repressive
strongholds the reason I come you know
it tables on a lot of things that they
said the openness to others especially
with LGBTQ I mean I get so frustrated
and the fact that we talked about
community we talk about being welcomed
well it's not necessarily always
welcomed in Texas and this is a home for
me it gives me hope I don't know what I
would do if I don't know only even after
seven years I live here it's like a
military enlistment it's not a home but
when I talk to you you're sincere when
Brett brings a message up it includes
everyone Brett lays it on line I've not
met many people you know to have a white
pastor talk about Malcolm X and to tie
it into a message that says you know the
acknowledgement I don't know what you're
going through you know that respects me
in my values I don't find that too
frequent
in the community and the older I get
I've just come to realize what I mean
people are genuine and real I've been
attracted to that and the rest I'm not
going to be and I agree with Juanita I'm
gonna do what's right not what's
expected of me but that's why I keep
coming back to the table so I also want
to ask about the church sphere
specifically because that's that's where
we are right now that's this spirit and
how where have you seen where have you
seen truthful speech and faithful
listening and responding break down
regarding the church and specifically
white majority churches for me it's the
breakdown is in is in your statement
it's in the truthful speech and faithful
listening that's where the breakdown
happen I in my experience truthful
speech is really hard right like it's
it's very difficult to hear things that
challenge your worldview or the
foundations that your life is built upon
and frequently or well in my experience
of majority white churches when you're
confronted with truthful speech from a
black person the first response is
denial because it's a challenge to what
your whole what you know the white
majority's whole world is built upon
it's a worldview and so we can't we
can't actually have truthful it's very
difficult now my hope people are
listening
it's actually very difficult you you're
Kinnear you know and it's um yeah
listening in that moment requires being
willing to have the very foundations
that your entire life is built upon
quite questioned and shattered in many
respects the experience of black people
in America and the experience of white
people especially white people in
suburban neighborhoods and areas are
very very different but it's easy in
white communities to build your bubble
to be in a bubble and to miss it
entirely so it's hard to hear and then
as a black person in these spaces it
requires a certain level of bravery of a
willingness to sacrifice and possibly
burn bridges to speak truthfully it is
it's very difficult to do and you we are
putting ourselves out here tonight and
we're at risk
maybe not for violence but for you know
people were in close relationship to see
this and take a fence or you know cut us
off or you know it's so I think I think
the breakdown is in in the very
statement it's it's being brave enough
to speak truthfully and brave enough to
listen well yeah I think it's been
difficult having to always be the
educator almost always be the one
talking and teaching and it doesn't make
sense to me that people don't want to
educate themselves and especially you
know if you don't know if you can't
understand how it feels to be a black
man or woman in America and you will you
will never
understand if you're if you're white if
you're not black you will never
understand and I think educating
yourself is needed because it's very
draining to always repeat yourself and
to have to be defensive all the time and
to feed into the stereotype that you're
seeing us you know the angry black woman
or the you know sensitive pressed
wanting to be oppressed you know I just
think that education and conversation is
needed and you know not many churches
are doing that and I'm so thankful that
the table has been brave enough to want
to have a conversation and want their
members to understand what people of
color go through and it's it's very
admire wool and Myron
[Music]
I guess for me two topics will be as an
individual because collectively
sometimes people see all black males and
black females is a collective for all
individuals we all have different
interests and that because really
difficult because someone goes no not to
offend well they've already started and
you know I have a friend that's black or
I have a friend that's mixed I know what
you go through no you don't sometimes
the best response would simply be I
don't know oh we can agree to disagree I
have more respect for someone that would
simply tell me I don't know because I
don't know everything and they don't and
then the level of sin sometimes people
just feel is something that can't be
overcome or Santa sent we're all sinners
we understand that and that's you know
why we come through that door
but I think that failure comes that you
know with my wife I can think back 20
instances are being judged
you know who you're with or what the
Bible says about a mixed race or what
the Bible says about your lifestyles and
the things that you do we know we fall
short but at the same time we're there
because we want the message and we want
to grow and we all grow different and
yeah I think I think that's why the
table it's hard not to come for that
message because it's not only fulfilling
but it fills a need you can go to church
all the time and gain nothing from it
you can just be there and in times like
this I can't just either that would only
frustrate me more you know I'm at a
point I've never been this frustrated in
my life thank God for counseling and
medication like I need to said we're
putting ourselves out there you know I
deal with depression and if that's a
weakness that is you know I have to be
truthful to myself and to those that
those are the points I missed in mine
and that's just in my opinion in my
perspective thank you yeah here why are
you saying that black people are not a
monolithic group and it's not on you
guys to educate the world like Google is
a great easy free resource like use it
there's I mean there's no excuse with
google podcasts articles social media I
mean gosh so many books so many so many
sources yeah and and by them like pay
money further read them and read them
yes well if anybody's wondering what
what can I do I don't know what to do
where do I start there that's yeah
what's a perfect place and how can how
can our community how can our table
community best support you and by that I
mean it's one thing to say oh yeah we
love you and we support you but like
tangibly tangibly practically what can
you
it's genuine love and care what
practically communicates love and care
to you I don't think it's just you know
I think first step you know educate
yourself and listen and want to have a
conversation that's the very first step
but I don't think that's enough I don't
think it's enough to just not be racist
you know I think at some point you need
to speak out and not just on social
media and on on Facebook Instagram
Twitter or whatever you need to educate
family members and I think showing just
support even whenever this isn't trendy
that's gonna be with what helps bring
change and even just brainstorming
solutions how can we make this better we
understand there's a problem and we
recognize it but not a lot of solutions
are being thrown out and that's one of
the most frustrating things cuz you know
I don't know how to I don't know what to
do I don't I don't know where to start I
do my part by speaking out educating
signing petitions going protesting and I
just I I want us as a community maybe to
just brainstorm how can we move on from
here what's the next step and to just
not be silent because that's be not just
not being a good person is just not
enough you have to speak out and so I
think in the end we just need to
understand and brainstorm what we can do
and how we can move on yeah I really
agree being a good person is not enough
like the bar is too low and part of
Education so understand that educating
yourself is an ongoing process like even
myself I am learning about police reform
defunding the police like I'm doing a
whole other side of research right now
to understand excuse
these new concepts the options available
to us for Public Safety so education is
an ongoing process additionally we are
not helpless um we are part of the
community and so we get to participate
and know how that community is run so
for example understanding our church is
located in saxy understanding the
government's and saxy understanding the
saxy budget understanding our school
systems and sexy and wily finding out
where the needs are and meeting those
needs excuse me we have the ability to
participate in an act peace in our own
neighborhoods but we have to educate
ourselves about our neighborhoods what
are the needs of our neighbors how can
we participate in the movements that are
already happening I think sometimes as
Church folks what do you think we're the
only ones doing it anything good but
there's good happening already out there
and so we should go find it and go help
and go participate I'm like India saying
that requires that we do more work than
just meet together on Sundays like we
have to do some work to learn our
legislators to learn our government to
be a part of the politics of our
community and I use that word
intentionally because we're so anti
politic in the church but politics
that's about your community living and
so if we're not involved if we're not
willing to do any work to understand how
our community is functioning then we are
not participating in making peace I mean
so for me for a church to begin doing
the work of deeply understanding the
community that it resides in and joining
in the movements and the good works that
are already happening in that community
providing momentum and resources and
work to bring peace in that community
that would speak love and care to me and
that will not just do good for black
people that will do good for trans
people and LGBT
q people and white people and our native
indigenous peoples and Muslim peoples I
think when we commit to bringing peace
actively then we can change the worlds
in which we live
we're not helpless but we have to get
outside of our sunday bubbles now I
agree you know getting out of that
comfort zone and getting to know others
and knowing your environment in being
prepared and educating yourself you know
my whole point of you know realizing
public safety what its role is what goes
on the escalating the situation wouldn't
even when dealing with law enforcement
everyone's nervous but you have to turn
around they're public servants you have
rights they serve you and how you come
across is it going to dictate how that
ends and it doesn't have to just be that
situation take it down and then go
through especially with the church the
table provides a great deal right now
and you know I just want to see it to
grow because to me the basis says a lot
because it's a foundation for a lot of
people you know I I see that and people
grow yeah it's tough being out here but
I think it provides that refuge it
provides those resources but ultimately
I believe it is gonna grow but it's
still that comfort zone for a lot of
people and then ultimately some people
will remain ignorant they may not
appreciate but at least they will
respect and I think that's sometimes all
we can hope for right now is just
finding a common ground we do what we
have to and spreading the word thank you
as we wrap up any final thoughts
anything we'd like to share in
conclusion just thank y'all for
listening you
yeah yeah you're preaching mm-hmm yeah
thank you guys like listening is the
least it isn't the least there's so much
more but I just want to thank each one
of you for sacrificing and for being
brave and for being willing to to be
present here tonight because that that
says something and it is cost to this
sacrifice it is courage and it is such a
gift to our community and those who I
imagine who are not part of our table
community that are watching this and so
yeah I we're we're indebted to you guys
and especially in the midst of the
heaviness and everything going on right
now I can't tell you how much it means
that you would you would be willing to
have this conversation right now with us
and so thank you and it's so good to see
your faces
I miss you guys I miss you oh that was
so good I'm just thinking about Juanita
in India and Chris's vulnerability and
honesty their courage their
truth-telling and sharing of themselves
it's a big deal and it does feel weighty
it feels weighty and important you know
and I don't want to gloss over that and
for those of you who are watching I want
to be clear that this discussion is not
intended to check a diversity box or
show some kind of performative focus on
behalf of the table it's really a step
towards community accountability once we
hear and bear witness we cannot pretend
not to know and once we
we cannot unsee and time will tell if
we're truly committed and doing the work
so this is this is communicating
something and it's something we want to
be held accountable to for those of us
who are white we have a lot to learn and
own and green white majority churches
we've caused harm damage trauma we've in
the past and and currently we minimize
dismiss deny and downplay harm instead
of being faithful listeners believers
and responders and I want to be clear
that it's not just racism that you can't
talk about racism without talking about
white supremacy and how whiteness
operates and both of those things are
sin and they must be rooted out and so
we have work to do so as a church
centered on Jesus we have a
responsibility to speak honestly to lean
in to the discomfort and for us to be a
faithful community of listeners and
responders it's our hope that this
discussion and this cultural moment that
we're in right now would not be a trend
it wouldn't be a bandwagon but that
instead it would be a catalyst for
awareness understanding repentance
healing solidarity and just in right
action in the way of Jesus let's pray
God I am so so thankful for Juanita and
India and Chris and how they've given us
their time their words their experiences
their perspectives and doing it in very
courageous ways and sacrificial ways
that is love in action and God I pray
that as we go from here we would do some
internal work God that your spirit
would guide us into repentance and
solidarity and being active peacemakers
not just staying in our sunday bubbles
but really learning and growing and
being active in our communities and God
just I just ask that you would empower
us and encourage us to do this work as a
community that we would be participants
in it that we would be those peacemakers
that you're calling us to be and that we
would be a community committed to our
values and committed towards being
visionary instead of reactionary so God
can't do this without you so I surrender
it all to you and I pray your blessings
of peace and grace over everyone
watching and a special blessing of
protection grace peace and rest over
Juanita India and Chris it's in Jesus
name that I pray amen
black people are so tired
[Music]
we can't go jogging we can't relax in
the comfort of our own homes we can't
ask for help after being in a car crash
we can't have a cell phone we can't
leave the party to get to safety
[Music]
we can't play loud music coats we can't
sell CDs we can't sleep can't walk from
the corner store can't play cops and
robbers you can't go to church you can't
walk home with Skittles
we can't hold a hairbrush while leaving
our own bachelor party we can't party on
New Year's Eve we can't get a normal
traffic ticket
we can't lawfully carry a weapon we
can't break down on a public road with
car problems
[Music]
we can't shop at Walmart we can't have a
disabled vehicle we can't read a book in
our own color we can't a ten year old
walking we can't a question we can't
cash our check in peace
we can't take out can't you would still
be live
I'm asking you we can't even peacefully
protest these types of making hashtag
[Music]
[Applause]
spilled on the street he was the roads
guys I just want to think India Juanita
and Chris again it means so much that
you would spend your energy and your
time here with us have the courage to
speak your own truth and to partner with
us so that we can be better listeners
and I just really really appreciate all
three of them thank you Karen for
leading us in this conversation and the
time you spent just making sure that
this could be fruitful and helpful and
it means so much so to all of you who
are here with us tonight thank you thank
you for doing the hard work of listening
and being able to open ourselves up so
that we can move forward and become
better in our closing I just wanted to
write a benediction that I wrote from
Philippians 2 to those who seek to
follow Christ may we find encouragement
from our communion comfort from his love
and
oh ship with his spirit may our walk
with Christ overflow into extravagant
compassion and genuine tenderness may we
listen to one another
long enough to be like-minded having the
same love and becoming one in spirit and
purpose may we find the strength to lay
our own preservation aside in order that
we might move from a place of selfish
ambition to humble service considering
others better than ourselves may we open
our eyes to look not only to our own
interests but also to see to feel to
embrace and to shoulder the interests of
others may we develop the courage to
take on the attitude of Christ Jesus who
did not consider equality with God
something to be grasped but instead
lowered himself so that others might be
lifted grace and peace to you all we
love you